PROFESSOR: All right, so lecture
10 was about two main things,
I guess.
We had the conversion
from folding states
to folding motions,
talked briefly about that.
And then the bulk
of the class was
about Kempe and Kempe's
universality theorem
and the beginning of linkages.
So let's start with an open
problem about converting
folded states to
folding motions.
This is a nice question.
So suppose you have a sheet
of paper like this one,
but it has a hole in the middle.
And then you
construct some folded
state of that piece of
paper with a hole in it.
And now you'd like
to actually get there
by continuous folding motion.
So the question is
why doesn't that work?
What we know is that the same
proof technique doesn't work.
We don't necessarily know
that it's impossible.
That would be a nice
problem to solve, actually.
So what difference
does the hole make?
So this is the
method we saw before.
You imagine having
some folded state, say,
from a flat piece
of paper to a crane.
You roll up that piece of
paper to a tiny triangle
that maps to a nice almost
flat portion of the crane.
Then you basically play
that motion backwards,
but on the surface of the crane
instead of on the flat sheet.
And that always works for
simple polygons, polygons
without holes.
If you have a hole in here,
you could imagine just
filling the hole.
That's what the
question suggested.
Just fill the hole,
do this thing,
and then remember that the
hole actually wasn't there.
Erase it again.
That should give you a motion.
Erasing the hole is fine.
The trouble is this part.
So if I define a folded state
of a piece of paper with a hole,
it doesn't tell you
where-- let's say
there's a little hole here--
this mapping won't tell you
where that hole goes in 3D.
You have no idea.
And in fact, it may
be impossible to map
the hole anywhere in this
folded state that's valid.
When you tear a piece
of paper, new foldings
become possible that were
not otherwise possible.
What's an example of that?
When I do a big tear
like this, now I
can pull these points
of paper apart.
And it's impossible to
fill this hole in in 3D.
It's possible to fill
the hole in here.
It's just suturing.
But when I separate
things, that means
the original sheet could
not fold into this state.
So you get new folded
states when you have holes,
that you cannot just patch the
hole and hope to find a place
that it folds over here.
There are other issues.
You could maybe patch it in
with some stretchy material
or something.
I have one example
in the notes where
you-- suppose you
have a tube of paper.
So this is not a flat example,
but it's an interesting example
anyway.
So let's say the outside
of this tube is purple,
and the inside is white.
And one thing you can do with
the tube is turn it inside out.
So you can make the inside
purple and the outside white.
So this is possible
with a tube of paper.
If you imagine this
as being a hole
and the bottom side is also
being a hole-- both of these
are open right now--
then you could also
imagine filling them in and
getting a cube of paper.
So in this case you'd get a
cube that's entirely purple.
This would be bad, because a
cube cannot be turned inside
out without self intersection.
So this is an
example where there
is a folding motion without
the holes filled in.
There is not a folding motion
when you fill the holes in.
So I don't know what that says
exactly about the problem,
but it's some intuition why
this is tricky business.
That's for a
polyhedron, of course.
If you're just trying to
take polygon with holes
and fill it in somehow, I
mean, maybe there's a way,
but certainly the obvious
way does not work.
What else did have
in my notes here?
All right.
Any questions about
that open problem?
Next question is about,
it's a neat idea.
We talked about linkages that
have joints like this one where
you must stay connected.
And then we briefly also talked
about a different kind of joint
where this vertex was pinned
right along another edge.
And we showed you
could simulate that
by just making a zero
area triangle here.
So you can force these
edges to come right
at this point of that bar.
Well, different
idea is what if you
allow this point to be able
to slide along that bar?
Is that some new kind of
linkage that's more powerful
or something?
Turns out, no, it's
not more powerful.
You can simulate that too.
So I thought I'd show that.
I had to think about it.
It's kind of fun.
This would have made a
good problem set problem,
but I decided to cover it.
So remember our good friend
the Peaucellier linkage,
which looks like this.
So these guys are equidistant,
and this is a rhombus.
All the edge lengths are equal.
Then this vertex lies
along a straight line.
And it has a limit.
Let's say it can go
this high and this low,
something like that.
We've seen that in
animation before.
So what I'm going to do is
imagine this as being my bar,
and this as my flexible point
that can move along that bar.
So here's the existing bar.
And if I want to add a point
that can' slide along the bar,
I'm just going to attach this
construction to this bar,
and this is where things
get a little bit messy.
These are the guys that are
normally rigidly on the ground,
but instead of them
being on the ground,
I'm going to attach them here.
So I'm going to attach this
to that, this to that, this
to that, this to that.
And because there's
two connections,
this is at the intersection
of two-- I mean,
this is a rigid triangle.
So these guys
can't move anymore.
But, well, they move
relative to this edge.
So however this edge
moves in the plane
or in space, whatever, I
guess in the plane here,
this guy will be forced
to track along the bar.
So if you don't worry about
intersections, which we're not
in this lecture,
this construction
you could attach
to any bar and make
a point that can
slide along the bar.
Kind of fun.
So you see the power of
Peaucellier linkages.
You can do all sorts of fun
constructions like this.
You could make it just
occupy a little portion
of the bar, whatever you want.
Just build the appropriate
Peaucellier linkage.
OK.
So we're into linkages.
Next we're into Kempe's
universality theorem, or sort
of Kempe's universality
theorem that he almost proved.
So one question just
to review, there
is this parallelogram
and contra parallelogram.
Pretty much all of
his construction other
than Peaucellier at the end
are a mix of these two gadgets.
And there's this issue that you
could flip one into the other.
Here we had, this was
the translator gadget.
If you have two parallelograms,
you can collapse one of them,
say, and then flip it out to
be a contra parallelogram.
If you don't do any
bracing, this can happen.
And this is bad.
You can actually see a few
ways in which this is bad.
One is here, we have
the parallelogram--
or, the point of this
translator gadget
was to preserve this angle
alpha, the green angle here.
It's supposed to be the same
as the green angle here.
But if you do this flip,
it won't be anymore.
It's the angle between
this and horizontal.
Right now this edge
is almost horizontal.
So the new angle's almost 0.
Here it's not.
Here's an example with
contra parallelograms.
This is our angle trisector.
If you line up this big
angle with something,
you get the thirds
of it, or vice versa.
We actually wanted to
use it to triple angles.
This is Kempe's
original drawing.
And if, say, this outermost
contra parallelogram
flipped open and became a
parallelogram like this blue,
then you'd be in big trouble.
These two angles no longer
equal this third angle.
So you'd no longer be
tripling or trisecting.
So that's why it's bad.
Next question is, how
did you fix it again?
I mean, the
parallelogram was easy.
I don't think I need to review
that using the construction we
already talked about.
Let me tell you a little bit
about the contra parallelogram
bracing, although it's very
messy to prove that this works,
so I don't want to spend
too much time on it.
The idea again was to take
the midpoints of the four
edges of the contra
parallelogram.
And first you prove those
always remain colinear
in the contra
parallelogram state.
They are not colinear in
the parallelogram state,
and that's kind of
what's good about it.
Then you find a magic point out
here off the board called X,
and X is going to be on this
perpendicular bisector of PR.
It's also the perpendicular
bisector of SQ.
Turns out this distance
always equals this distance
by the symmetry of
contra parallelogram.
That's actually
really easy to see,
because you have opposite
edge links being equal.
You get that symmetry.
So it turns out that has to be
a fairly specific point for this
to work.
All right.
So what do we do next?
And then we add these four bars.
And the harder part of the claim
is at that this thing still
moves within an
appropriately chosen X.
I kind of don't want to
get into that too much.
The easier part to see is
that you can no longer-- if X
is sufficiently far down there,
this is no longer possible.
So let's prove that first.
So let's see.
If you look at
these bars, the bar
PX and RX have the same length.
That means however
you fold this thing,
X must be on the
perpendicular bisector of PR.
Here, that's fine.
Over here, the perpendicular
bisector would be, I guess,
some thing like this, I guess.
All right?
So the perpendicular bisector
of PR some ray like that.
OK.
And simultaneously
for the same reason,
X must be on the
perpendicular bisector of S
and Q. S and Q are these
opposite midpoints,
and so you've got to be in some
kind of perpendicular bisector
here.
If you have to be on both of
those lines, that means in fact
you must be at the center
of this parallelogram.
Or, I don't really
need this as a center.
It's some point inside
the parallelogram.
That's really bad for X. If
these links are really long,
say, longer than the perimeter
of this linkage, then
X has to be outside,
because, yeah.
If it has to be far
from S, R, Q, and P,
you can't be inside the polygon.
OK?
So provided these lengths are
sufficiently long, say longer
than the perimeter,
there's no way X is inside,
and yet in the parallelogram
state it has to be inside.
And so the parallelogram
stays impossible.
So that's the easy
part of the proof.
The tricky part is
to get this thing
to still fold when this is in
the contra parallelogram state,
that X is still OK here.
And I'll just mention
to convince you
that it's tricky-- you set
the length of the XS bar
must be in square, this thing.
XS bar squared must be the XP
bar squared plus 1/4 AB squared
minus AD squared.
And I won't go into the proof.
There's some details
in the notes here.
But what this says is that we're
talking about XS versus XP.
The other two are symmetric
, so they have to be equal.
So XS has to be a
bit bigger than XP,
and this says how much bigger.
The formula says
how much bigger.
They can both still
be very large,
so we can still get
the part that we need,
but we need that
they're actually
related in this way for the
whole thing to hold together.
And I will leave it at that.
Sorry, it's a
little unsatisfying,
but the details are
just not that exciting.
If you're interested
in them, you
can read Tim Abbot's
master's thesis,
which is on my web page.
Cool.
I wanted to briefly remind
you about some of the project
ideas for Kempe before we go
to generalizations of Kempe.
So one of them is
to implement Kempe.
It's never been implemented, as
far as I know, in general form.
And it would be
interesting to actually see
it happen in action,
some version of it.
There's a lot of
different versions,
but ideally with
bracing, I guess.
Another fun sort of
more design project
would be to design
an alphabet and be
able to make every letter of
the alphabet with some linkage.
That doesn't have
to follow Kempe,
but it would be in the
spirit of signing your name.
And I have here one
example that's on the web.
I'll show you the web page of
making the letter C. Here's
what it looks like in action.
So it's just a four bar
linkage, pretty simple.
I mean, it's three bars
plus this closing bar.
And then you look at the
midpoint of this edge,
and it happens to trace
out this kind of letter C.
So if you had a pen there,
that's what it would make.
You could imagine just a whole
bunch of these in sequence
and be another kind
of mathematical font
which would be fun to have, so.
A lot more, 25 open
problems left to go.
I think I could do a circle.
I can do an O, so.
24, and these [? fall ?] fast.
Another direction
would be to build
some kind of sculpture
inspired by Kempe.
This is one by Arthur
Ganson since called Faster!
And if you've been to the MIT
Museum, you may have seen it.
Sometimes it's out, although
I've never seen it running.
But there's a video of it online
if you want to check it out.
So this is a device.
It's a kind of push cart.
It's a sculpture push cart.
You have to run
with it, and as you
run, the wheels
power these gears,
and the pen there
with the hand signs
faster, as in you
should push it faster.
It's pretty crazy.
Now, this could be done
with Kempe, but in this case
it's not.
It's done with these
weirdly shaped gears.
And those weirdly shaped gears
control the different axes
of the pen.
X, Y, Z, N, in and out.
You can see it actually lifts
up to do the exclamation point.
So that's one sculpture
inspired by Kempe.
In general, there are lots of
ideas for making sculptures out
of linkages.
Arthur Ganson is
particularly cool in making
linkage-like sculptures
that move kinetically.
If you haven't been to the
MIT Museum to see his stuff,
you really should.
It's super cool.
All right.
So that's that.
Next we go on to
generalizations of Kempe.
So there are few
questions about this.
One was higher dimensions,
how exactly does that work?
Particularly D equals 3.
If you want to follow
a surface, does that
mean the linkage now has
two degrees of freedom?
The answer is yes.
You get to choose.
If you want to
trace out a surface,
you'll have to have
two degrees of freedom.
So it's not just turning
a circular crank.
It's more like a spherical
crank, which is indeed
what my hand can do
relative to my elbow is move
along a sphere, well, maybe
a half sphere or something.
So that's what's possible there.
If you want to trace
out a 3D curve,
then you only have one
degree of freedom, of course.
I thought I'd briefly tell you
a little bit about how 3D works,
or show you one of
the constructions,
which is the
Peaucellier linkage.
So here is the 2D
In 3D, this won't work.
Well, it won't work in
the sense that this guy
is rather unconstrained.
But if we add, let's see,
it's a little hard to see.
Imagine a plane here, a vertical
plane through these points.
So if this is in
the board plan, I
want to choose a point that's
roughly here out of the plane.
I'm going to draw that here.
And then connect it
up the same as before.
So it's connected to here.
It's connected to here.
And it's connected to there.
So it's just a third
point just like these two.
These two are symmetric, so
this one's also symmetric.
And all these lengths
are equal if you put it
at right C coordinate.
Then this is like
a 3D Peaucellier.
I don't think
Peaucellier invented it.
Probably we did,
but the result is
that this point will
lie on a plane out here.
So that's cool.
It's like the higher dimensional
version of Peaucellier.
Now if you actually want this
point to move along a line,
what would you do?
AUDIENCE: Intersect two planes.
PROFESSOR: Intersect
two planes, exactly.
Take two planes, intersect them.
It is a line.
There's the line
of intersection.
Generically, you get a line.
Unless they're the same
planes, you always get a line.
So if you take two
Peaucellier linkages,
you overlap them
at this one point.
Then this point,
on the one hand,
these two points are pinned.
We'll have to line one plane.
On the other hand, I'll
have to line another plane
from the other
Peaucellier linkage,
so you can force it to
stay on an actual line.
And both of these
gadgets are useful.
Sometimes you want
things to stay in planes.
things to stay on lines.
And once you have this
construction, in fact,
you could build the
old Kempe construction,
and just put in a ton of
3D Peaucellier linkages
to force everything to
stay in the XY plane.
And then anything you could do
in two dimensions you can now
do in three dimensions.
So that's observation one.
You can do Kempe in the Z
equals 0 plane, the XY plane.
And that's the
basic idea for 3D.
You do all the stuff we're
used to doing in there,
all the angle doubling, adding
new addition, all these things,
and then you just
have to translate.
You have some points in 3D.
You need to measure their
coordinates or the angles
they form with
other edges in 3D.
You just map all those
things into the XY plane,
do your computation on the XY
plane, and then map them back.
I won't talk about that
mapping, but it's not too hard.
And once you can map anything
you want into the XY plane,
you could do your
computation, map it back,
and force your points
in three dimensions
to have whatever
properties you need.
So you can write down any
polynomial now in X, Y, and Z
and set that equal to
0 just like before.
Do all the trig
expansions you did before,
and you can force a point to
trace exactly that curve in 3D.
So that's just a
sketch of how 3D works.
Skipping some details
because there are messy.
The idea is very simple.
3D Peaucellier.
All right.
Next question is
related to-- properties
is mentioned in
the lecture notes.
So there's a couple
versions of this question.
They're asking the same things
at different levels of detail.
So what about curves not
represented by a polynomial?
I read this like, well,
that's not possible.
Everything you make
out of linkages
has to be represented
by a polynomial.
That's true, but what about
piecewise polynomials?
That is possible.
So you can do piecewise
cubic splines.
If you've ever drawn a curve
in a vector drawing program,
you've used splines.
So those are
splines, and they're
made up of little polynomial
pieces, like maybe
of a parabola here, and then
you design it to transition say,
C2 into another parabola,
or then into some hyperbola,
whatever.
So these kinds of
general curves,
you can do great
things with splines.
Pretty much every curve you've
seen on a computer is a spline.
And this is much better than
the Weierstrass approximation
theorem which we talked
about before, which
says you design one
polynomial that approximates
an entire curve,
like your signature.
But when it does that,
it'll be like this.
It's a very ugly-- if you use
various pieces of polynomials,
say all cubic
polynomials, you can
get some really
nice looking curves.
So you can really
reproduce your signature.
And there is a theorem
mentioned in the notes that
says you can trace any
semi algebraic set.
So I want to define
semi algebraic,
because this is actually
closely related to splines.
It's a little more general.
So what's a semi algebraic set?
So here's an example of
a semi algebraic set.
You have some polynomial,
let's say on XYZ,
and you want to say this is
greater than or equal to 0.
So it's a little different.
Before, we could set
polynomials equal to 0.
Now I can set them greater
than or equal to 0.
So that's the semi part
of-- if we just have this,
this is an algebraic
set, essentially.
Semi algebraic, you can have
half spaces in some sense.
And then you can also take
unions and intersections
to form an algebraic set.
Also compliments, but
it doesn't matter.
So what does this mean?
It means I can
take all the stuff
on one side of a polynomial, and
then-- well, on one polynomial.
Sorry, that's what I should do.
So here's, let's
say, my parabola.
I can take this
region, and then I
could say, OK,
well, let's take--
this gets messy to
do-- I could take also
all the stuff outside
this polynomial.
So that's some
bigger region here.
I could take the union of those.
I could clip off parts.
Basically I can construct
a spline in particular,
but in general I can do
lots of different things
by unions and intersections of
these polynomial half spaces.
So this lets you
construct splines.
It lets you piece
together components,
because, for example, I
could take this curve.
And then on one
side intersect it
with the other side Greater
equal to 0 and lesser equal
to zero, then I get
exactly just this curve.
And then I can, for example,
cut to the left of this line.
And then I'll have this curve,
but only if it stops here.
I could do the same
thing with this piece,
end up with this
piece, and then take
the union of those two pieces.
So I can construct a spline.
I can have regions, of course.
Infinite area, finite
area, whatever.
So semi algebraic
sets are very general.
It's fairly easy
to see that this
is the most you could hope
for, because in general, you
look at a linkage, it's defined
by polynomial equations.
You say, well the
square distance from P
to Q equals L for
various things.
So you only have polynomial
equations to work with.
Because you have flexibility,
you get inequations.
Because we can do
things like this.
I mean, this distance
is now less than
or equal to the sum
of these two lines.
So semi algebraic
sets are the best
you could hope for, a bunch
of polynomial inequalities.
And in fact, every such semi
algebraic set is possible.
So how do you prove that?
It's actually really easy.
We've essentially
already done P of XYZ
is greater or equal to 0,
because we saw in Kempe how
to set something equal to 0.
To do that, we used the
Peaucellier linkage,
which I will draw
for the Nth time,
because I need to modify it.
So here's a Peaucellier linkage.
It forces this point to
lie on a straight line.
If I add a joint here, and
basically let this length
get smaller if it wants to-- it
can do things like this now--
I should draw it more like that.
Maybe I should draw it
scale, so that's maybe
something like this.
This point can now move
anywhere on the segment.
Then this guy will end up being
able to make, well not exactly
this half plane,
but a region of it.
A big enough region if
you set it up right.
And as you may recall,
the x-coordinate
here was the sum of
all my trig terms.
And I wanted that equal
to 0 for this to happen,
but if I wanted to make
greater than or equal to 0,
then I just needed to be to the
right of that vertical line.
And so that lets me
take any polynomial
and set it greater
or equal to 0.
So that's basically Kempe,
except I used this modified
Peaucellier that let's things
go to the right a little bit.
OK.
Intersections are also easy.
If I want to take the
intersection of two sets,
I just overlay those
linkages and let
them share the same point.
I call this P that
we're constraining.
So that will apply multiple
constraints to that same point,
and so that is the intersection
of those two semi algebraic
sets.
The one tricky part
is unions, and this
is what the question
is asking about here.
Intersection gadgets are clear,
but what's the union gadget?
Union gadget turns out to
also be possible using Kempe.
Kind of surprising.
Let me show you how.
So suppose you have
linkage one constraining
some point I'll call it P1 here.
And you have
another linkage two,
constraining at some point P2.
And what you'd like to do
is build a new linkage that
has some point P that either
follows P1 or follows P2,
so it takes the union
of those two sets.
So whatever L1 constructs for
P1, whatever L2 constructs
for P2, you want to be able
to trace P1 or trace P2.
And what we're going to do
is build another box here,
another linkage, which
is going to be-- I
won't write L. Got
some more room here.
It's going to be a
Kempe construction
for this polynomial.
So this polynomial,
it's a little different
from what we've seen.
And over here it's going
to be point P. P here
is X comma Y. P2
is X2Y2 and so on.
If you want, as X1Y1.
So this is an equation
involving three points.
In the past, we've only
had polynomial equations
involving one point.
This is another generalization
of Kempe which I may or may not
have mentioned, but
it's really easy.
We had, what was it, a rhombus
to represent a single point.
You just have three of them,
and now you've got three points.
You could do the same trig
identities, and so on,
to expand out.
You get, you might not
call it a polynomial,
you might call it a multinomial.
Well, I guess it was already
a multinomial in X and Y.
Now it's a polynomial
on XY, X1, Y1, X2.
Y2.
And that's exactly
what we have here,
various powers of
those six variables.
You expand them out just in the
way you did before with trig,
and you just need to be
able to add up angles now,
not just alpha and
beta, but now there's
six possible angles representing
each of the x- y-coordinates.
So I claim I can build
this thing of Kempe.
OK.
And if I build this
thing, basically I
force X and Y to be
either X1, X2 or Y1, Y2,
and that lets you take the union
of link [? which ?] L1 and L2.
The new point P can either
live at P1 or can live at P2.
Questions about that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Should some
of those be pluses?
PROFESSOR: Should some
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
looks like X
equals X1 is enough to
make that whole thing 0.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I was curious about this.
Do you see a way to fix this?
The worry here is X could be X1,
and Y could be Y2 [INAUDIBLE].
So you have--
AUDIENCE: X minus X1
squared plus Y minus Y1
squared all [INAUDIBLE]
X minus X2 squared plus Y
minus Y2 squared.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Plus-- this is extremely ugly.
OK, let me maybe rewrite it.
Thanks.
Yeah, as I was writing
this I was like--
AUDIENCE: Squared
in the wrong place.
PROFESSOR: Squared plus
Y minus Y1 squared.
And then this thing
times yeah, thanks.
Same thing with 2's.
Equals 0.
So the product being
equal to 0 means
one of the two terms
better equal 0.
And in this case, if this
equals 0, because of the squares
it forces it to be
non-negative, which
means the only time
the sum is equal to 0
is when both of the terms
are equal to 0, which
means X equals X1
and Y equals Y1.
So this plays the
role of and here,
and the product
plays the role of or.
So either XY equals
X1Y1, or XY equals X2Y2.
Thank you.
Good fix.
Just make a quick note of that.
Do I have a pen?
I won't.
OK, so that is how you do
intersection of two linkages,
is just Kempe again.
It's kind of cool.
Any questions about that?
Once you have
unions, we've already
done intersections
in half spaces,
then you can make any
semi algebraic set.
So what I think would
be cool in particular
is to implement Kempe force
spline, say, quadratic splines.
Because Kempe for
quadratic polynomials
is going to be
pretty reasonable.
You have to implement this
union gadget to piece together
the pieces, which
is kind of messy,
but in principle, you can piece
together a bunch of polynomials
and see what a
spline looks like.
You had a question.
AUDIENCE: So if the curves
you're taking in enough
don't intersect to get
from point to the other--
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yeah.
So you're asking about sort
of continuous crank ability
of Kempe constructions.
And indeed, if you had two
sets that were disjoint,
there's no way to continuously
go from one spot to the other.
What this is saying is that the
overall trace of this point--
if you look at all possible
configurations, the linkage,
and then just see
where P goes, it
will trace out both of
those connected components.
On the other hand,
if these do overlap
if there is a common point
between these two linkages,
then this will allow you
to transition from one
to the other.
So right, if you're
building a spline,
presumably you know
that they're connected,
and you want to be careful of
the way you union them together
to make them possible
by continuous motion.
I think that's always possible.
But you do have to be careful.
Other questions?
All right.
I want to get the hypar
gluing, but there's
one more topic some
people asked about,
which are these origami axioms.
I mentioned them very briefly
at the end of lecture 10,
and they sounded
amazingly powerful.
They let you solve
all these things.
The setting here is something
called ruler and compass
constructions.
How many people here have
heard of ruler or straight edge
and compass?
Almost everyone.
A compasses is this
gadget like this.
You can draw circles with it.
And there's a standard
mathematical formulation
of a straight edge and compass
which is, if I have two points,
I can draw a straight
line through them.
If I have two points, I can
draw a circle through them
like that.
And if I have lines and circles,
I can take their intersections.
And if that's all
you're allowed to do,
then you can prove that if you
look at the coordinates of all
the points you
make-- and let's say
you start with one point
which I'll call 0 comma
0, another 0.1 comma 0.
So I have the number 0 in one.
Then the numbers you can make,
the coordinates you can make,
are everything you
could make from 0 to 1
by plus, minus, times,
divide, and square root.
You could do all
those operations,
and that's all you could do.
And so what that
means basically,
is you could solve quadratic
polynomials, but nothing more.
And that's an old result from
1800s and implies things like
you cannot trisect an angle.
You can bisect an
angle because that only
involves quadratic stuff.
You can't trisect an angle,
for example, 60 degrees,
because that involves solving
subcubic, which is not
possible by straight
edge and compass.
You cannot compute
the cube root of 2.
It's a cube doubling problem,
so all these great things.
Then came along Huzita in
1989, and at the same time,
Jacques Justin in
1989, who you remember
did Kawasaki's theorem
and Maekawa's theorem.
He also did this,
all independently.
So Huzita suggested
these axioms for folding.
If I have two points,
I can fold a crease
along those two
points, that line.
If I have two points, I can
fold a point onto a point.
That constructs a
perpendicular bisector.
If I have two lines, I can
fold one line onto the other.
That is the angular bisector.
If I have a point and the line,
I can fold the line onto itself
, which forces the crease to be
perpendicular and pass through
this point.
You see these in lots
of origami diagrams.
They let you find
interesting lines.
If I have two
points on a line, I
can fold this point
onto this line
while also folding
through this point.
That's a tangent of a parabola
if you look at it correctly.
And if I have two
points and two lines,
I can fold this
point onto this line
while simultaneously folding
this point onto this line.
There actually is four
or eight different ways
to do it in general,
but you can find them
all by just
manipulating the paper.
That's the claim.
There's one other that Huzita
missed, Justin saw, called,
these days, Hatori's
axiom, where
you fold a point onto a line.
And not shown here, I
believe, is another point
that you must fold through.
No, that looks like this axiom.
So I've forgotten what the
differences is for Hatori.
Oh, not drawn here is,
there's an edge in the bottom.
And you also want
to fold the line
onto itself, which
means you have
to be perpendicular to
this black line down here.
So that's sort of
all you could imagine
if you have these sort of
points onto lines, lines
onto points, lines onto lines.
Axioms, if you
enumerate them all,
this is all of them
for a single fold.
And with these axioms
you could prove
you can solve any
cubic polynomials.
So basically you can
also take cube roots.
And so in particular, you can
do things like trisect an angle.
It's what's shown up here.
Fairly small sequence.
This was discovered
in the 1970s.
You can trisect any angle,
divide it into thirds
just by these kinds of folds.
And the tricky operation
here is folding two points
onto two lines simultaneously.
That's the third
degree operation.
Everything else you can
do with ruler and compass.
And you can also do
things like double a cube.
This is computing a
cube root of 2 ratio.
First you bisect you
thing into thirds.
This is easy to do, because
we can divide by three.
Then you fold these two
points onto these two lines.
And it turns out the ratio
here between this y-coordinate
and this y-coordinate
is cube root of 3.
A over B is cube root of 3.
This is by Peter Messer in 1985.
So that's kind of cool.
But that's all you can
do with single folds.
The most you hope for is
solving cubic equations.
You can't quintisect an angle.
You can't divide
an angle in fifths.
You can't compute the
fifth root of 2, I assume.
You can't do lots of things.
But it's at least more powerful
than straight edge and compass,
which is cool.
So then this was just for
single fold operations.
You could look at
two fold operations,
three fold operations
where you make
two folds and simultaneously
align lots of things.
With two folds you can-- oh,
sorry, before I get that.
There is a software called
ReferenceFinder by Robert Lang,
if you're curious about how
to construct various things.
So here is plugged in, I
want to compute a third.
And it just enumerates
all possible things
you could do with
five or six folds.
And if it finds
an exact solution,
it will put it at the top.
It also finds
approximate solutions
which are practically useful.
So this is a sequence of
operations that from a square,
you could find this point at
0 comma third, which is nice.
When you have two folds,
you can quintisect an angle.
These are Robert Lang's diagrams
for quintisecting a given
angle.
You can see at the very
end here we have an angle
and it's divided
evenly into fifths.
It's a bit complicated,
and at some point
it involves a two
fold operation.
It says here.
Here's where it all happens.
Your fold here, and
simultaneously you fold here.
And you have to align all these
points and lines and things.
And that's cool.
I think with three folds, they
can solve any quintic equation.
That's Alperin and Lang.
And then the culmination,
which I mentioned briefly
at the end of lecture 10,
is if you allow end folds
simultaneously,
then you can solve
a degree end
polynomial [INAUDIBLE]
order N. First you set
up your piece of paper
into all these independently
manipulatable limbs.
You mark off these
coordinates, which
are the lengths of the bars
in your Kempe construction.
And then you say,
well you've got
to fold so that this
all these points align.
That will construct
a linkage state,
and if you set Kempe
up right, there
will only be one state,
which is the solution
to your polynomial.
So that's one way to do it.
There are actually
other ways to do it.
Alperin and Lang have
another solution.
It's a little more
simple, but this is fun
because it uses Kempe.
And that is a brief
story of origami axioms.
Any questions about that?
There's a small
chapter in the book.
It's called Geometric
Construction.
I didn't prove anything here,
because it's a little bit
tedious to prove.
You can solve any cubic, you
can solve all these things.
That's the most you could solve.
But all these things have
been completely characterized.
I guess there isn't a complete
characterization of, say,
two fold axioms, exactly
what you can make.
That's still open.
But the point is, as you add
more folds, you get more power.
Eventually you get
all polynomials,
which is the most
you could hope for,
for any kind of
geometric construction.
If there are no
more questions, we
resume our task of
building something out
of hyperbolic paraboloids.
Remember this is the
hat construction.
If you have a square
in your polyhedron,
you take four
hyperbolic paraboloids
and join them together
like this picture.
And then this is going
to represent one edge.
Those two edges of
the hypar are going
to represent one
edge of the square.
And I was suggesting we
make this shape, which
we have enough hypars for.
We just need to do some taping.
This is the truncated
tetrahedron.
It's got four triangles,
four hexagons.
So we've already
made-- last time
we made the four triangles.
These are the three hats, and
they can be joined together
to form a tetrahedron
by themselves.
We've got enough hypars
to make the four hexagons,
and then we just need
to tape them together,
and we will get the
truncated tetrahedron.
Who would like to help?
Come on up.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yep.
PROFESSOR: It will be
something like this.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: I think we need
a whole other six, but.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Is there another roll
of tape hidden somewhere?
[INAUDIBLE]
STUDENT: And the other
main thing is [INAUDIBLE].
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] these
two on a triangle here.
It's like 36.
Sort of.